Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khoa học
ích theo miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube và Excel bài số
14 các thủ thuật Excel 2 phần 1 trên 4
trước khi bắt đầu bài học ngày hôm nay
mình sẽ giải đáp câu hỏi của bài số 13
hôm trước nhé để các bạn xem ở cái câu
hỏi của bài 13 lên ok câu hỏi bài 13 là
mình sẽ sử dụng cái Flashtool để mình
phát họ tách tên và sách kĩ năng và
thánh của ngài tuyển dụng ở đây không ạ
thì đầu tiên để tách họ thì bạn chỉ cần
nhập về tên họ của các bạn đầu tiên ở
đây thì đoạn thì gọi cao đấy ạ Đấy sau
đó bạn bấm xanh cho nghe thì lập tức
toàn bộ họ của các cách mạng này đã được
điền vào đây lại rất là nhanh ạ tên cũng
vậy nhé Thì bạn chỉ cần nhập tên là ví
dụ đây mình nhập là cô này các bạn sẽ
bấm tensione lại đây là cái kiếm sắc của
cái class kênh nhé tương tự thì để lấy
năm của ngài tuyển dụng ở đây Các chỉ
cần nhập năm vào đây rồi đấy Sau đó các
bạn muốn các Chanel
anh Thắng cũng vậy nha con sẽ nhập 11
vào đây đấy Gọi chú nhé khi các bạn Nhập
11 vào đây thể Excel nó sẽ lấy cái 11
đầu tiên ở bên này sẽ là nó sẽ hiểu là
ngày cho nên nếu như mà để lấy tháng chứ
không phải nhập thêm một cái mẫu nữa thì
ở đây là cái tháng 10 nhé Thì bạn sinh
nhật chú về rồi đây Thì như vậy sao cái
mẫu Thứ hai này tức là cái tháng 10 của
cái dữ liệu thứ hai ở đây này thì nó mới
sử dụng lắng khi được nha các bạn thứ 4
KCF Đấy Tình Như vậy là nó sẽ điền tháng
rồi đấy Ok như vậy là mình xong cái câu
hỏi của bài số 13 nhá các bạn đóng lại
cho mình Bây giờ mình sẽ vào bài 14
trong bài 14 ngày hôm nay mình sẽ làm 4
thủ thuật thứ nhất là đánh số thứ tự
động thứ hai là di chuyển dữ liệu từ
mang là sáo trống và thứ tư là tự can độ
rộng của cột ở mỗi thủ thuật bị mình sẽ
để ở một cái xếp riêng biệt để các bạn
có thể tiện theo dõi nhé mình sẽ để cái
link tải file thực hành trong phần mô tả
em heo thì tốt nhất là các bạn tải về
các bạn vừa theo dõi và thực hành cùng
mình nhá Nếu bạn nào không biết cách tải
về thì các bạn có thể xem cái bài học
đầu tiên thì trong bài đấy mình không
dẫn các bạn chi tiết cách để các bạn tải
về thì thông thường những cái file tải
về sẽ là cái thai nghén bạn sẽ giải nén
ra nó sẽ có 2 file một là phải thực hành
và thứ hai là cái file câu hỏi để các
bạn làm bài tập về nhà nhá một số bạn có
cần men trong người nhện là khi các bạn
tải về các bạn không giải nén được thì
thông thường máy tính của bạn nó có phần
mềm diệt vi rút đi thì nó hiểu cái file
đấy là cái file mà chứa virus thì trước
khi tải về thì tốt nhất là các bạn sẽ
tắt hoặc các bạn Apple cái phần mềm diệt
virus đi nhé để các bạn tải về đấy thì
sau khi các bạn tải về các bạn giải nén
lên và các bạn thân bật lại cái tính
năng diệt ví dụ của các bạn nhé Ok mình
sẽ vào cái thủ thuật đầu tiên là đánh số
thứ tự động cái việc đánh số thứ tự này
các bạn rất là hay dùng này thì giả sử ở
đây mình có thông tin của các bạn
ạ Bây giờ mình cần điền số thứ tự thì sẽ
có một số cách cơ bản nhất để điền số
thứ tự Cách thứ nhất là gì mình sẽ nhập
hay các bạn đầu tiên ví dụ là một này
các bạn Thứ hai bạn sẽ nhập số 2 Đấy sau
đó bạn Bôi đen hai cái dữ liệu này để
các bạn sẽ trỏ chuột vào cái góc dưới
bên phải của với bạn Thứ hai này khi nó
hiện lên dấu cộng thì gọi sẽ kết thúc
vào đây đấy thì như vậy nó sẽ tự động nó
liền cho tất cả các bạn học sinh còn lại
để rất là nhanh ạ lấy là cách 2 dùng hết
nhá Cách thứ hai là gì ạ Các bạn chỉ cần
nhập số 1 vào cái ô đầu tiên đấy Thôi để
các enter sau đó rẻ các bạn kéo cái số
một này các bạn kéo xuống dưới đấy khi
bạn kéo xuống dưới thì nó sẽ hiện một
cái ô Nhỏ đây đấy thì họ sẽ thích vào
cái phần này nó gọi là auto pin option
có thích ở đây sau đó có thích và cái
mục thứ hai là phim Siri là đấy thì ngay
lập tức sẽ miền cái số thứ tự động còn
lại đây rất là hai ạ
3 Cách thứ ba là địa các bạn có thể điểm
số 1 của Đây nhá đầy sau đó thì các bạn
Kéo xuống và các bạn giữ cái phím
Control đây này đây sau đó các bạn bỏ
trái ra và các bạn bỏ thím cần sơn ra
đây là cách thứ ba nhé Ngoài ra thì có
một cách cách thứ tư nó cũng khá là ngay
với cái trường hợp mà dữ liệu của các
bạn giải ví dụ nó có hàng nghìn hoặc
hàng chục nghìn hoặc thậm chí là đến
hàng triệu dữ liệu thì các bạn không thể
kéo chuột được đúng khi còn kéo như thế
này nó sẽ rất là chậm với cái trường hợp
mà dữ liệu của bạn nhiều thì cái cách mà
người ta hay dùng trong trường hợp có
nhiều dữ liệu thì bạn chỉ cần nhập cái
thứ tự đầu tiên này sướng cái thứ hai
các bạn sẽ bằng các bạn lấy cái hàng
trên này các bạn cộng một đấy enter thì
sau đó bạn chỉ cần copy các dữ liệu mà
có cái chứa công thức các bạn tăng lên
một đây này để các bạn copy và các bạn
xuống cuối nhá Đây thì chả sửa đây là
cái cuối dữ liệu rồi các bạn giữ tiền
ship vào mũi tên lên đấy Sau đó bạn bấm
enter hoặc các bạn có thể bấm cân survey
Ví dụ mình em tơ đi
có cách cách ngày nó sẽ áp dụng cho các
trường hợp mà dữ liệu của bạn rất là dài
đúng không Thì sau khi mà các bạn có
được cái số thứ tự rồi thì các bạn lên
page nó thành vali để cậu sẽ tích vào
cái cột bên này con nhé hiệp phải các
bạn copy cái gọn nhớ thì phải tiếp các
bạn vessel các bạn kết 3 live Các bạn
bấm ok nhá Đấy thì như vậy dữ liệu ở đây
đó chuyển thành số rồi đấy ạ Ok tranh
thủ thuật thứ hai là việc di chuyển vùng
dữ liệu thì các bạn thuế nhé với mỗi thủ
thuật điện mình để hướng dẫn ở bên phải
lại rồi để các bạn có thể tiện theo dõi
và các bạn ghi nhớ Nó thuận lợi hơn nhá
Đấy thì trong cái phần di chuyển này
mình sẽ hướng dẫn cho các bạn một số các
thủ thuật sau đầu tiên là các bạn di
chuyển hàng chính hãng nhá thì các bạn
sẽ Model khác cái Hàn mà các bạn cần di
chuyển này Ví dụ mình cần di chuyển cái
hàng thứ năm và thứ sáu nhé thì các bạn
thấy cực trái vào cái hành số 5 Này các
bạn kéo xuống dưới lại như vậy mình đã
lựa chọn hai cái hàng là hàng thứ 5 là
thứ sáu rồi đúng không ạ Các bạn sẽ Di
chuột vào một cách bất kỳ của khách hàng
thứ năm và thứ sáu này đấy Khi mà nó
hiện Kim
em chỉ ra 4 hướng thì các bạn giữ được
trái và ngăn kéo đây các bạn kéo xuống
ngân hàng mà các bạn mong muốn nhé ví dụ
mình kéo rồi lấy hàng này đi đấy thì như
vậy là dữ liệu của hàng thứ năm và thứ
sáu là được hôm đây để bây giờ các bạn
có thể kéo về nhá lại ví dụ phân tích về
đây có kéo về để cạn dưới chạy và các
bạn kéo nhá Đấy đã cạn bảo vệ trái ra Ok
bây giờ để di chuyển cục nhá thì bạn là
diện các bạn sẽ lựa chọn các cái cột mà
các bạn cần di chuyển lại để bạn giữ
chuột trái và bạn Bôi đen bay cùng này
sau đó bạn Di chuột đến một cái cạnh bất
kỳ này khi nó hiện mũi tên ra bốn hướng
này các bạn giữ được trái và các bạn kéo
đấy các bạn kéo ra cái vị trí mà bạn
mong muốn nhá Đấy bây giờ để kéo về các
bạn cũng Di chuột trái và kéo sang đây
thôi đấy để di chuyển một cái vùng dữ
liệu Giả sử mình di chuyển cái vùng dữ
liệu này đi đấy các bạn muốn em cái vùng
dữ liệu mà các bạn cần di chuyển nhé sau
đó bạn giữ được trái và các bạn kéo ra
một cái vị trí mới đây Bây giờ các bạn
có thể kéo về lại rất là hai ạ bây
ý mình muốn lại mình muốn đổi các bạn
Trương tăng sinh này lên trước Thế bạn
Đỗ Văn Đậu thì mình là như thế nào thì
bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái bạn chương trình này
các bạn không mua cái phần số thứ tự nhé
Tại vì mình muốn cái số thứ tự nó sẽ rẽ
nó vẫn là như thế này đấy thì các bạn
chỉ cần bôi từ cái phần họ tên đến cái
phần tổng điểm thôi nhá sau đó còn giữ
được trái và các bạn kéo lên cái vị trí
mà các bạn muốn và các bạn phải giữ cái
phí ship cho mình đây thì sau khi mà các
bạn giữ phím shift thì nó sẽ hiện một
cái điện một cái đường kẻ đậm mà nó sẽ
gạch ngang vào cái hàng mà các bạn muốn
di chuyển đây các bạn sẽ di chuyển và
các vị trí và các bạn muốn nhé các bạn
nhớ là các bạn phải giữ vững ship cho
mình nhá Đấy thì nếu như mình muốn gì ạ
một mình muốn các bạn chương trình này
lên trước các bạn đủ vận động nhá Đợi
tức là diện trước cái hàng Thứ 6 này đấy
thì bạn sẽ di chuyển nên giữa bạn Đỗ Văn
Đậu và bạn Bùi Thị béo ở đây đấy Sau đó
bạn bảo tuyệt trái ra đấy và các bạn bỏ
các phím sim ra đấy thì như vậy các bạn
chương trình đã gì lên trước các bạn Đỗ
Văn Đậu là rồi lại các bạn
chị Hai ạ Bây giờ giả sử việc các bạn
Bùi Thị béo này nhé Mình muốn di chuyển
nó xuống Cuối cùng thì các bạn Bôi đen
các bạn Bùi Thị béo này và bạn di chuyển
xuống dưới và các bạn phải giữ vững trí
cho mình đấy các bạn bỏ chuyện trái ra
và sau đó có mấy bảo hiểm ship đấy Bạn
thấy hồng rất là hai ạ bây giờ trong
trường hợp mà mình muốn copy cả cái bảng
dữ liệu này ra một cái vùng khác thì làn
rẽ các bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu
mà các bạn cần copy nhá sau đó bạn giữ
trái và quan kéo đấy nếu như mà bạn muốn
copy thì các bạn phải giữ thêm cái phím
cần trôi đây khi mà các bạn giữ phím cần
trôi thì các bạn nhìn thấy cái dấu cộng
ở các vị trí của con chuột nhá đây tức
là cái dấu cộng này nó hiểu Nghĩa là
copy đấy Bây giờ các bạn sẽ bỏ từ trái
ra thì sau đó các bạn ơi bọn phím cần
chôn ra thì như vậy mình đã copy bảng dữ
liệu này rất là nhanh chóng ạ xanh thủ
thuật thứ ba là mình sẽ xóa các ô trống
nhá thì cạn chuối nhá ở đây giả sử mình
có danh sách là họ tên của các sinh viên
này
ưu điểm của các môn nhá ở đây bạn thấy
không có những cái ô mà nó sẽ có trống
nhá Bây giờ làm sao để mình xóa những
cái ô trống này đi thì Cách thứ nhất các
bạn Thúy lại ở đây mình đã nói rồi bước
thứ nhất mình chọn Toàn bộ người cùng dữ
liệu thì các bạn sẽ được trái và các bạn
Bôi đen toàn bộ cái vùng dữ liệu này
trong trường hợp mà dữ liệu của các bạn
vẫn dài các bạn không thể mua chuột trái
ngang được thì các bạn chỉ diện tích và
mô bất kỳ sau đó bạn bấm tăng chân a
cũng được đấy thì nó sẽ tự động nó vui
toàn bộ vùng dữ liệu cho mình nhé Để sau
đó bạn vào thẻ hôm này hãy chọn vào file
and select đã Cậu thích ở đây firex và
các bạn chọn thì các bạn chọn goto
special đấy và các bạn chọn cái một like
nghĩa là gì Tức là những cái ôm mà ô
trống ở đây này ông rỗng ấy thì nó sẽ
Bôi đen cho các bạn nhé họ sẽ thích ok
đấy như vậy các cái ô trống đây này Nó
đã được Bôi đen rồi nhá bây giờ để xóa
các ô trống này các bạn rất đơn giản các
bạn sẽ nháy chuột phải vào một ô trống
bất kỳ Ví dụ mình nhá được phải vào ô
trống F4 anh nhé để cậu nhớ phải các bạn
chọn thì các bạn chọn đi
Ừ thì nó sẽ hiện một cái cửa sổ để mình
chọn cái tùy chọn Delete nhé ví dụ mình
chọn hiện dịch chuyển từ trái sang tức
là địa các ô nó ở đây thì nó sẽ dịch
chuyển sang bên trái tức là diện từ phải
qua trái Đấy thì nó sẽ dịch ở bên trái
có diện tích Ok Để thì như vậy toàn bộ
dữ liệu nó đang được miệng nó sẽ được
đẩy sang trái rồi bây giờ có thể undo
nhá Cái phím tắt để mình mở cái cửa sổ
ghoshal vừa xanh Nhã ví dụ tích vào đây
đi để mình thoát cái phần lựa chọn nhé
thì các bạn có thể bấm phím tắt là căn
chung giờ đây thì nó sẽ vào cái phần Go
tù ở đây và các bạn chọn cancel đấy thì
nó giống như các bạn vào thẻ hôm này các
bạn vào file save và các bạn chọn gotos
theo rồi Thôi thì các phím tắt là các
tên g nhá sau đó qua chọn bảo anh ạ Đấy
đấy là các phím tắt nhá Ok xanh cái tủ
thuật cuối cùng là mình sẽ tự căng độ
rộng cột đấy thì chả sửa đây nhá mình có
dữ liệu là các cái thông tin của họ vào
em ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ tự động cắt cái độ
rộng cột thì cảm thấy nhé ví dụ cái số
thứ tự này cái độ rộng cột để nó lại quá
rộng Nó không cần thiết thì nhìn nó rất
là xấu đúng không Trong khi họ tên này
thì cái cột này nó lại quá làm bé đấy
bây giờ để nó căng cái độ rộng cột tự
động thì các bạn làm như thế nào giả sử
bây giờ mình muốn căng cái độ rộng cột b
này nhá thì bạn sẽ vào đấy các bạn xem
vào giữa cái cột b và cột C đây này khi
nó hiện cái mũi tên mà nó vẽ hai bên đấy
thì các bạn sẽ thích lúc nhé để thích
đút vào đây này thì các bạn sẽ nhìn thấy
cột b nó sẽ con ạ Các bạn thích nó đi
đấy thì cần thấy em cái cột bên này đã
con lại trong trường hợp với mà bạn muốn
mod nhiều cái nhiều cái cột Ví dụ mình
cần cột C này Đấy cột e và cột g đi
chẳng ạ Đấy thì các bạn sẽ thích vào cột
C các bạn giữ gần chôn các bạn tích của
e các bạn giữ từng chôn có mặt tích của
g đấy nhá Thì các bạn xem vào một cái
cột bất kỳ Ví dụ mình và cái của em đấy
nhá Thì họ sẽ Di chuột giữa cái cột a và
cột f này khi nó hiện mũi tên ra hai bên
các bạn sẽ thích nước vào đây đấy thì
như vậy ba cái cột C của E của f đã được
viện nó sẽ được tự động căn cái độ rộng
cột thì cái độ rộng cột này nó rộng như
thế nào thì nó sẽ dựa vào cái dữ liệu mà
có cái độ rộng lớn nhất để nó sẽ căng
vừa cái ôm đấy thì ví dụ như cái họ tên
nhé thì cảm thấy là cái bạn Nguyễn Văn
Cam này nó sẽ có cái độ rộng lớn nhất
thì nó sẽ căng cái độ rộng của các cột C
này để vừa cái bạn Nguyễn Văn Cam này
Đấy đấy là cái nguyên lý của cái đối
rộng cột nhé Ok Bây giờ bạn có thể ăn
lưu lại trong trường hợp mà bạn muốn sẽ
tăng cái độ rộng cột của toàn bộ cái
bảng này thì các bạn sẽ Bôi đen toàn bộ
các cái cột của cái vùng dưới nghiệm này
để sau đó còn Facebook vào đây đấy Bạn
thấy không đấy là cái cách mà mình sẽ
tăng độ rộng của nhiều cột Ok như vậy là
mình đã xong bốn cái thủ thuật của bài
học ngày hôm nay bây giờ mình sẽ xem cái
câu hỏi của bài tập về nhà nhé Ok bài
tập về nhà là gì ạ thay cái ô trống bằng
cái đoạn trích là thiếu dữ liệu
ô tô màu vàng tức là cách ô trống đây
này các bạn phải gõ cái chữ thiếu dữ
liệu và các bạn phải tôi với màu vàng
lên đấy đấy là cái bài tập về nhà nhé Ok
như vậy là mình đã kết thúc bài học ngày
hôm nay ở đây cảm ơn các bạn đã theo dõi
các bạn nhớ đăng ký Kênh để cập nhật
video mới nhất của gà cũng như chia sẻ
để giúp mọi người cùng học ít xem nhé
Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại ở